quiz time what's your favorite childhood
toy and if you're still a child what's
your favorite current toy my favorite
childhood toy
was you ready for this y'all ready for
this
teddy ruxpin
so my poor teddy he uh he's lacking an
eye here
uno is back in the form of teddy ruxpin
hi there my name is teddy ruxpin how are
you today
fine well then i would like to teddy
ruxpin
the world's first animated storytelling
toy
now available at stores everywhere
i accidentally threw him in this wooden
cradle that we used to have when i was
younger that we used to keep all of our
dolls and toys in and poor little teddy
face planted
right onto the
wooden side and lost his eye but
previous to him losing his eye
he used to read me stories and he would
growl at me because there's something
wrong inside i don't know my dad tried
to fix him but he never got fixed so
poor little teddy would be reading his
story
once upon a time blah blah blah blah
blah i was in the forest of dancing
dancing dancing
and behind his his beautiful voice his
little reading voice
would be
this hideous growling sound
but i couldn't sleep without him i
needed him he read to me
actually that's my
my bed from when i was a child
i'd be napping
and teddy would be
as you would read my stories
yeah i know
pretty tragic
so my question to you
what is your favorite childhood toy and
again if you're still a child
what's your favorite current toy teddy
and i'm gonna go have some quality time
together
with the panda bear
me
you